I love this next one this is just a good
old-fashioned political dressing down
now in general it's really common that
when presidents go to sporting events
it's sort of a smattering of cheers and
boos and very frequently there are boos
no matter who the president is no matter
what their approval rating happens to be
at the time and part of that is there's
a lot of people who just want to see
sports they don't want presidents there
at all
they don't want it made political in any
sense and that's a common thing that
takes place at sporting events Donald
Trump over the weekend went to the fifth
game of the Major League Baseball World
Series played in Washington DC and he
was not only met with resounding boos
but also chance of lock him up Donald
Trump showed up with a whole cast of
characters and criminals including
Senator Lindsey Graham that totally
disgusting congressman Kevin McCarthy
vile Republican Matt gates and a whole
bunch of others and there was a lot a
lot a lot of booing take a look
[Music]
and then the chance of lock him up
breakout here's another recording of the
LA come up chance and it is just it's
it's like a beautiful symphony on a
chilly fall morning in Boston as you
observe the foliage just hearing this
[Applause]
it's also hilarious that Donald Trump
was asked to and declined to toss out
the first pitch I think we know why
Donald Trump can't throw it would have
been an incredible embarrassment to his
suppose at alpha-male status if he went
out there and threw out a first pitch
instead chef Jose Andres threw out the
first pitch and he is a big big critic
of Donald Trump and it was funny to see
him do that as well now genuine question
here Baron Trump is 13 years old today I
mean it's not his birthday today as of
today he's 13 years old I have no idea
if Baron Trump likes baseball
but you see your dad take Lindsey Graham
to the World Series instead of you that
seems a little odd to me I don't know
what's going on there one of the notable
things is that Donald Trump actually
looks visibly shocked that he's being
booed by the entire stadium and this
gets to something I've been wanting to
talk about for a while Donald Trump
truly seems to believe that the echo
chamber in which he lives of Twitter
blocking anybody he doesn't like golf
courses where everybody is just you know
brown-nosing rallies with hand-picked
sycophants he seems to really believe
that's America he seems to think that is
the the mood of the country and that's
why he believes any poll that shows he
has a 55 or 60 percent disapproval
rating must be fake news suddenly he
shows up in front of a crowd that was
not hand-picked for him and it's a
veritable disaster you can visibly see
when Donald Trump realized that the boos
and the chance of lock him up are for
him and he tightens up and he becomes
like a different person
now there's another funny thing about
this the anti Obama right throughout
Barack Obama's presidency thought that
everybody felt like that crowd about
Barack Obama they thought everybody
hates this guy Obama left office with a
59 percent approval on the last day in
office an approval rating Donald Trump
has not even come close to having at any
point during the nearly three years that
he's been in office Trump literally
cannot go out in public if it's actual
public not one of these curated audience
at a rally
he can't go out in public without being
despised and booed I saw funny comment
online it was something like hey listen
some people were booing and some people
were cheering what'd you think of Donald
Trump determines whether you heard the
cheers or the boos this sort of it's all
equal it's all perception that's all it
is very postmodern by the way of some
defenders of Trump
that's not how sound works some people
were cheering you can't hear them over
many of those boos this is like that
Simpsons episode I haven't watched The
Simpsons and so long but some episodes
really made an impression on me there's
an episode where mr. burns kind of like
the you know old rich conservative white
dude equivalent he's getting booed
somewhere in public and he asks are they
booing me no no no sir they're saying
boourns burns they're cheering for you
mr. burns very good thank you here it is
one more time there are military service
members on the big screen people are
cheering for them
the second the screen flips the Trump
the booing explodes
[Applause]
quite a day really truly delightful ah
why does he even do that my biggest
complaint about all of this is come on
you're supposedly the alpha male throw
out that first pitch I would love to see
that there have been bad first pitches
and people have survived Gary Dell'Abate
Howard Stern's producer he had a doozy
where I think he hit an umpire in the
back of the head about 30 feet off
center or not off the centerline just
pitched that first pitch I would Bush
did it Obama did it John Kerry was even
photographed throwing footballs or
catching footballs just do it Donald
Trump I would love to see it a
delightful event fun for the entire
family